COLT MCANLIS: In this episode
of "Cloud Performance Atlas,"
I help some medical
professionals improve
their video upload speeds.
Will their performance get
a clean bill of health?
Stay tuned to find out.
A few weeks ago, I met
with the Medic 7 research
group, who were seeing a
consistent problem with the GCS
upload speeds they had.
Their clients would make
a video of a genetic test
or a chemical reaction
and then spend
a number of hours waiting
for the four-gigabyte file
to upload.
When you're moving at
the speed of science,
those type of delays are costly.
To get a sense of what
upload speeds look
like with very large
files, I pushed
a bunch of 100-meg,
200-meg, and 500-meg files
to GCS using the Python API
and charted their performance.
While still really
fast, we see that there
appears to be a slight
upper limit with respect
to upload speeds for
a single large file.
What's interesting about the
problem is that the Medic 7
group had only ever been using
the Python API for uploads,
because if you use the
gsutil for the same option,
you get this handy
warning any time
you try to upload a large
file, which politely suggests
that you should be using
composite uploads for the best
performance.
See, with composite
uploads, gsutil
can split a large file
into smaller pieces, which
are uploaded in parallel
and then composed
back together in
your GCS bucket while
removing all the temporary
components properly.
For Medic 7, the
performance difference
between the blob and composite
uploads is immediately visible.
Running the same test showed
almost a 2x improvement
in upload times.
For more information on using
composite parallel uploads
and how to work with the crcmod
requirement for the clients,
check out the article linked
in the description below.
And for more great tips
on optimizing your cloud,
make sure to check out the
rest of the "Cloud Performance
Atlas" content.
Because, when it
comes to performance,
every millisecond counts.